tu vas faire sur votre technique avec un
peu fort vous êtes c'est ici qu'est les
plus belles hôtesses de roissy donc moi
à chaque pause dej depuis trois mois je
viens au starbucks viol de toiture c'est
à dire le le starbucks tu si c'est là où
les hôtesses vont prendre leur café
et donc quand tu as créé leur commande
mathieu note leur prénom et leur boisson
préférée dans mon petit carnet dans le
carnet c'est à dire bah c'est assez
pénible c'est à dire que là par exemple
c'était dans mon carnet les hôtesses
qu'on a arrêtée là le vol sao paulo
paris c'était noté alors on a un allongé
pour sa race comment vous c'est allez on
se lance sur le numéro alors c'est parti
c'est pas bien
je t'aime mais dis pas je t'aime tout de
suite ses généraux mais si sincère je
devais vraiment au [ __ ] si elle bat
les cafés j'étais plus frais c'est quoi
ça sert du dodo récompense mon avis un
cutter si le mec s'est fait chier à
venir jusque là on va lui prendre un
paquet d'oser regarde voilà il est là le
don ce n'est pas sérieux je fais part et
j'écoute on l'a retrouvé votre doudou
quoi déjà la récompense comment
s'organise je pensais à 100 euros 150 ça
fait un compte rond à lorient demain
contre on sent ça va vendre aux parois
si monsieur s'est tué 92 ma fille
invoquant plaisir nous à roissy quand on
peut rendre service mais c'est pas
nouveau m'a fait ça ça passe à succès
comme je peux peut-être vous aider à le
retrouver
sofiane michel fera pas tant d'argent
tant que j'ai pas d'oubli de mafieux
entre les mains c'est clair at en
revient aux [ __ ] de nuit ici qu'est
ce qu'elle est bonne c'est ma femme 1 1
voilà on l'a retrouvé le nounours
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait mamie la norme
amis n'ont pas ce doudou c'est pas fini
là ya pas marqué pigeons et c'est
important et à la place c'est à dire
lesdites menaces de doigts tu sais ce
que c'est qu'un doudou une police qui
sont mauvais c'est un objet
transitionnel qui permet un enfant en
situation de stress affective de se
sentir en sécurité on est sur wii qui
fait qu'un fils ne peut pas s'endormir
sans son doudou nos champs plus marron
et je vais donner à ma petite fille
nous sommes dans la recherche médicale
non non pas du tout
non mais ça va pas elle est longue cette
journée
notre guide mais juste récupérer une
bibitte me fuis moi j'aimerais vivre en
colocation et jésus christ pas possible
on a tous nos rêves combien
en touche au but c'est mon nom c'est que
je vais toucher au but c'est une
obsession chez toi ça s'appelle être
pauvre